The core idea behind defining all of our traits is the idea that
we're not just one trait, but a collection of all of our traits together.
>> We all have our own stories about
what it's like to live with different traits,
and we're all different because of the environment
we live in or certain combination of traits.
>> And help us on our journey
of understanding the biological basis for many of
our traits. We're going to be sharing personal
stories from individuals from all walks of life.
>> We've
recruited five people that we're going to talk
to extensively throughout the whole course, and see
what it's like to live with their certain
traits, and how these traits affect their life.
>> Our group of five individuals consists of a visible and hidden traits
That have come to shape who they are in both small and big ways.
>> By the end of this course, you'll be familiar
with the particular traits these individuals represent, and the biological
significance of having these variations.
>> You know, let's, let's go meet 'em.
>> Let's do it.